i'm in paris france
i've come to a little forest on the
outskirts of the city
i'm here to meet a young woman
struggling to figure out who she is
one of the three people we'll be talking
to during the show
i follow a path down to a little camp
tucked away here on the edge of one of
europe's most expensive cities
the place looks deserted
no one comes out to meet me but i can
hear noises and voices coming from the
huts
there are no names or numbers to tell me
who lives where
so it's up to me to look for alina the
young woman i'm here to meet
hello
alina lives here with her boyfriend her
parents and her two sons live next door
like everyone here she's a member of the
ethnic roma minority she tells me it's
living like this in the camp that makes
her feel ill
day
is
foreign
fear is something that alina and other
roma living in illegal camps in france
know all too well
from 2012 to 2013 the number of
evictions more than doubled already this
year almost 11 000 roma have been
removed from their homes by french
authorities
alina works as a volunteer helping
others living in camps she translates
for those who don't speak french makes
them doctors appointments and registers
kids for school
alina says it was back in romania that
she first realized she was different
class
i'm shocked to see not only the level of
poverty some roma experience right here
in the french capital
but also how cut off they are from
society
only bad things
i want to find out what other people
really think about one of europe's most
disadvantaged minorities
france is
most roma come from romania and bulgaria
as eu citizens they have the right to
live in france
alina has joined a program for young
roma volunteers
it's designed to help them find their
place in life
a
i've joined a group of roma children and
volunteers on a trip to the seaside in
normandy
for many kids it's their first time ever
at a beach
not all of them go to school in france
so for some this is a rare chance to
experience life outside the camp
alina is 24. she left her home in
romania at 15
and got pregnant shortly after
she now has two sons
parenting didn't come naturally while
alina was moving between countries she
had to leave the boys with her parents
in romania
and sometimes didn't see them for months
back in the roma camp in paris there's
music this time
it's a completely different atmosphere
compared to my first visit
it's alina's 25th birthday and she's
invited family and friends to celebrate
can feel a strong sense of community
here
and despite all the hardships alina has
not lost her spirit
i still wonder how living on the margins
of society has shaped how she sees
herself
foreign
when i asked alina what her life would
look like in a perfect world
she says she would be living in the
united states
i hope that she doesn't stop dreaming
and that life will someday get easier
for her